oh the first song i ever wrote  [Music]  and it was like a bluesy thing it was  like there was my voice doing that and  then it was like  all by himself  no other one around  and he stood all alone  when would he be found  did he want company  or was he fine on his own  everyone needs a friend  so why was he  all  you know he's like but i was like a 12  year old with  i just felt  like depressed for the first time and i  was  and i just was like  he discovered the blues as the 12th yeah  right right it really was like my sense  of the blues at that time for sure like  bad version of the blues but it was like  12 year old kid with a bunch of acne and  like i just like i hated going to school  i felt like that i i just had not found  myself that's like a great song by the  way but i wanted to keep looking i  forgot i was  you